several Las Vegas showgirls speaking out
a day after they were attacked on the
Las Vegas Strip thank you for joining us
at 11 I'm Brian Loftis and I'm Denise
Valdez police say a man
a maple kill Ed who in a random attack
and now those affected are grieving
while trying to come to terms with what
happened Sasha Loftus joins us live
tonight from UMC with their story
Denise and Brian these girls say they
were just doing their jobs when a man
came up and started stabbing them one of
them speaking to us from our hospital
bed here at UMC we do want to warn you
the details in this story may be
disturbing
and I'm screaming
asking everyone to spell hours after she
was stabbed on the Las Vegas Strip Anna
Westby shares her harrowing story
and stabbed me in the back
and then you read off she's one of four
Showgirls attacked Thursday morning when
police say 32 year old Johnny Barrios
went after eight people unprovoked
killing two including fellow showgirl
Maris diogiovanni who was stamped in the
chest
I got up and then I started running
I started yelling he has a knife
Victoria kaitano was also working when
the worst happened
she's now home from the hospital but
emotionally she's anything but okay I
couldn't believe that this was happening
to me a tight-knit group managed by
Cheryl lothorpe owner of best Showgirls
in Vegas Unsure how to move forward
after 12 years of safety in the business
this is a safe job
there are cops everywhere no place is
filmed more than the Las Vegas Strip
they say all they can do now is be there
for each other and remember Maris she
was exceptional
she was exceptional she was
on fire beautiful and and smart and
radiant while trying to cope with the
idea that something so horrible could
happen
now there is a GoFundMe setup for all
four girls affected by this attack as
well as a separate GoFundMe by me uh by
her family the woman who died Marissa's
family if you would like to donate and
help with funeral expenses reporting
live tonight Sasha Loftus 8 News Now